-It is always great
to see you, bud.
-It's great to see you,
my friend. How you doing?
-Great to see you in person,
as well.
Thank you for doing
our shows all the time.
But I want to
say congratulations.
You have a
brand new-baby at home.
-Yes.
-Brand-new!
-Yes. A new baby boy.
Yeah. His name is Rydin,
and I love him.
-Dude, congratulations.
-I'm exhausted.
-Yeah.
-Exhausted.
-You have to be exhausted.
-Yeah.
-And, I mean,
did you forget about that?
I mean, because you have --
-Yeah, you kind of
do forget about it.
It's like an evolutionary sort
of thing. I don't know.
-Sleep deprivation is
a terrible --
-Just like, "Oh, my God."
I got to sleep
on the plane, though.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-But here's the thing I find --
you can't tell your wife
that you got to sleep.
-No. I know. No. No, no.
-It just makes everyone angry.
If I get like an hour nap,
I go, "Honey,
I just had a great --"
And she's like,
"Oh, that's great.
I've been up all day."
-"Good for you. Good.
I'm happy for you."
-You brought some
cute pictures of the baby.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-This is day of?
-Yeah, this is the day of.
Aww!
-Oh, get ready. Get ready.
-Oh!
-Look at that!
-He's so cute!
-No, he's really cute.
Look at this.
-Yeah, look at him.
-Two eyes open. Hey, bud!
-And look at this.
Look at that.
-Oh!
-Yeah!
-Now he's going back to bed.
-Yeah, of course.
-He's just the best, yeah.
-It's the greatest thing in
the world. Congrats.
'Cause you also have
a 4-year-old.
-I have a
4-year-old daughter, Story.
Hi, baby.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, she's madly in love
with him,
can't squeeze him enough.
Like, lays on top of him,
suffocates him.
You know.
-Yeah. That's what you do.
That's what you do.
-I mean, it's her doll.
You know?
-Yeah. It's a living doll.
-Yeah, I'm like,
"No, this is real life.
-Yeah.
-It's a real baby."
-Has -- I know Bryan Cranston
is a good friend of yours.
Has he seen the baby yet?
-He has. He has met the baby.
You know, I asked Bryan
on his birthday
if he would be
our baby's godfather.
Yeah.
-Oh, I'm assuming --
-Yeah.
-I'm assuming --
-He said "no."
-Okay.
Well, it's fine.
He's a very busy man.
He's a very busy --
-He's very busy.
No, he was very excited,
very honored.
I love the man to death,
you know?
He's one of my best friends
in the world,
and, so, yeah,
it was just a no-brainer.
-You guys have reunited as your
characters from "Breaking Bad."
-Yeah. And I can't believe
that we can talk about that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was supposed to be --
You know, we're going to be
on the new season
of "Better Call Saul,"
which just started airing.
-Yeah.
-So watch it.
[ Crowd cheering ]
But -- Yeah.
I didn't think that
we were going to be
able to talk about it.
-I think half the time
you've been on my show,
we weren't allowed to talk about
anything you've done.
-Yeah, it's weird.
This business is weird.
-But it's --
-You know?
-But that's so exciting!
-Yeah, it is exciting.
I'm very excited.
-Can you tell us anything?
-No.
Well, it was nice to zip on the
skin of Pinkman again, you know?
-Yep.
-It was strange.
It was a lot of the same crew
from "Breaking Bad"
is working on
"Better Call Saul,"
so it was just nice
to be reunited
with this beautiful group
of people out in New Mexico.
-Wow.
-You know -- Yeah.
-I mean,
'cause that's your family.
-That's my family!
-Yeah.
-It's my old stomping grounds.
-"Breaking bad" is considered
one of the greatest shows
of all time.
And I know you have
so many famous people
that love the show,
but I heard that
the Rolling Stones
are giant fans of
"Breaking Bad."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Was it a musician thing
or was it a --
-You know, I got invited to
a Stones concert, by the Stones.
It was like, "Wait. What?
Okay. Well, yeah.
I will go, you know?"
I'm like, "Who's inviting me?"
They're like,
"The Rolling Stones are."
I'm like, "Yes, I will go."
I show up.
They're like, "Ronnie Wood
wants to tour you around
before the show.
Can you show up early?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I can do that."
-"I can do anything."
-Yeah, and then he
brings me, you know,
to Keith Richard's
dressing room,
and he's shirtless,
smoking a joint, and I'm like,
"This is such
a rock-star moment, you know?"
-That's what you want.
-That's what I want, baby!
-Come on, buddy.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
your new movie, "Dual."
Okay, this --
It's in theaters now.
In Finland, by the way,
is where you shot it.
-Yeah, I shot it in Finland.
-Gorgeous, Finland.
-Beautiful.
Birthplace of saunas.
-That's right!
-Yeah.
-Who doesn't love a good sauna?
-Exactly. I love -- Yeah.
I almost didn't make it
to Finland.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I was packing to go to Finland.
It was the first flight
I ever went on since COVID,
and I went to grab my passport
and I realized it was
my old passport.
I couldn't find my new passport.
And I'm like,
"I can't make my flight."
And we were trying to get a rush
passport delivered, you know,
an appointment set up,
and my wife's like,
"The only appointment --
I booked it for you.
It's tomorrow morning,
8:30, in Honolulu.
I got you a flight."
Don't stress.
They're not --" You know,
'cause I was thinking
they were gonna recast me.
And then, so,
I had to get on a plane.
On the way to the airport,
I stopped off
to get passport photos
and then got on
a plane to Honolulu.
The next morning,
did my, you know,
rush-passport thing,
got a passport in three hours,
flew back, and then, on the way
to the airport the next day,
I got in a car accident with two
identical yellow Ferraris.
It's so -- It was like
all the signs were like,
"Don't go to Finland."
-Wow!
-When you watch the movie,
you'll see in the special --
you know,
"special thanks" section
at the end of the movie,
they thank my wife,
my friend Philly,
who lives in Honolulu,
and Chris Barcelona, who worked
at the passport agency.
-Chris Barcelona, thank you...
-Chris Barcelona,
love you, buddy!
-...for getting this movie made!
-Yeah. Love you, man.
-It's a fun movie.
It's a really interesting movie.
I love a good plot.
I love a well-written thing.
The idea is that you can clone
yourself if you're dying
just so that your family
can grieve.
So you could be dead,
but you still exist.
-Yeah, you know, it's to help
with, you know, the loss.
But then -- You know,
the character
that this story follows, Sarah,
she finds out she's dying,
so she has herself cloned
to help her family mourn.
But then she finds out
she's no longer dying,
so she has to ask
her clone to be terminated.
The clone does not want
to be terminated,
and so they have to fight
to the death in a duel.
-Exactly right.
-Yeah. So, I play Trent,
and I'm her trainer.
I help her get ready
for the duel.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Aaron Paul in "Dual."
Take a look at this.
-If you know that you do not
care if you live or die
in your duel, you may as well
tell me right now.
I will tear up your contract,
and you can spend all the money
that you save over the next year
on drugs and alcohol,
vacations to the beach,
sex, trips to amusement parks.
You will surely die
in your duel,
but you will have lived
your last year on Earth
in an excessive
and exciting fashion.
-I said I want to live.
-Are you prepared to kill?
-Yes.
-I believe you.
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aaron Paul, everybody!
"Dual" is in theaters now.